oh after spending a few precious hours
watching the attorney general testify
today
before the house budget committee i
thought one thing
why on earth did bill barr volunteer for
this type of abuse
leaving the comfort of his retirement
just to have to answer
to some of the nastiest people on the
face of the planet
nida lowey of new york badgered bar on
his synopsis of the mueller report
all we have is your four-page summary
which seems to cherry-pick from the
report
to draw the most favorable conclusion
possible for the president
and make definitive legal conclusions
in less than 48 hours i would argue
it's more suspicious
than impressive a knee-jerk liberal
or just a jerk well after watching this
next clip
you decide your conclusion
is something we've seen before in june
2018 you wrote a memo
as a private citizen and a former
attorney general
to the department of justice laying out
the president's case
against obstruction of justice
your audition clearly went well
your edition clearly went well wouldn't
you just love to read bill barr's
subliminal thoughts about this entire
charade scrolling at the bottom of the
screen oh i'd pay big money for that
attorney general didn't need this he
already was attorney general don't
forget almost 30 years ago when he was a
lot younger
and probably had a lot more patience but
like so many others in this
administration
i'm thinking bob lighthizer at ustr
wilbur ross at commerce alex azar at hhs
steve mnuchin at treasury betsy devos at
education
they all left their very comfortable
lives and moved to washington
to help solve problems and make a
difference
that's what civil service is supposed to
be all about isn't it
but this is what they deal with instead
like alex azar at a recent senate
hearing
about the detention of alien kids
we are getting 300 to 350
unaccompanied alien children crossing
the border and referred to hhs
every single day right now these are
10 12 13 15 year old kids they're not
coming with parents they're coming
across the border by themselves
what is the capacity of the child prison
system that you're that you're seeking
with this money you keep saying
prison system if you've got an
alternative approach to how to care for
these children please tell us because
well let me
give you that you wanted to it would be
nice i mean let me explain to you that
i loved it that's what every cabinet
secretary should do in these hearings
turn the tables on these people
congress has the power to fix the
immigration laws don't they
and if child attention or separations
are so offensive
hey why don't you change the laws better
yet seal up the border
and end this travesty altogether
now of course congress does have
legitimate
important constitutional obligations to
do proper
oversight of the executive branch i'm
all for it but what the democrats have
been doing since trump took the oath of
office
isn't oversight it's character
assassination
either of the president himself that he
was secretly working with the russians
or of anyone who works for him
look at what the jackals did at
secretary mnuchin's hearing today
well now get this we have a crisis on
our southern border
and all impeach 45 mad maxine cares
about is trump's old tax returns
secretary mnuchin will you comply with
the law by the deadline tomorrow
as i said before we will follow the law
you're not afraid that you will be fired
if in fact you release the returns
well i i i'm not afraid of being fired
at all
i've said we will follow the law
and i'm very pleased you're not afraid
of being part
now coming up empty there auntie maxine
went back to her favorite category
i'll take russian oligarchs for 500. i
don't believe i've ever
met a russian oligarch so you never met
or talked with i had any conversations
with mr derek
or with um mr victor vekselberg
or anybody about sanctions is that
correct that is correct i've never met
either of them no no not matt but had a
conversation with perry
i've never had any conversation with
either one of them okay
let us continue
the gentleman from north carolina
ranking member mr mchenry is recognized
for five minutes
by the way that went on longer there
okay she's just a complete and utter
embarrassment
along with pelosi the co-ruling queen of
the resistance
how is any of this helping their
constituents the answer is it's not
now the republicans remember they're
also called the gop as in the grand old
party
i'm thinking democrats should be called
just
up as in the unserious party
okay because for more than a year the
trump
team undertook the painstaking process
of doing things like
renegotiating nafta the trade deal that
had given unfair advantage to companies
that moved their plants to mexico
canada and mexico both signed off on it
so why hasn't nancy pelosi called it up
for a vote
because she's unserious she's parroting
bogus concerns
of her buddies over there at the afl-cio
about labor laws in mexico
it's a big issue how labor people are
workers are treated in mexico and to
lift up our own
workers you don't do that by suppressing
workers in
other countries that it's an
exploitation
on both on both sides
i don't know what that was she and beto
should get together
exploitation i haven't heard nancy
demand the same from china lately
have you they don't do anything with
labor law problems the truth is pelosi
wants to throw sand in trump's
gears every chance she gets if obama
hadn't negotiated the same deal
she'd have been all for it but she'd
rather deny trump a victory
than do the right thing by the american
people same scenario by the way is at
play with the ongoing
invasion across our southern border
congress could fix this
in a weekend now estimates are
that this month alone we could see a
hundred
and fifty thousand migrants overwhelming
our border our border patrol
so instead of closing loopholes ending
this crisis democrats
just use every opportunity to grandstand
for the cameras
department of homeland security is
descending into chaos
a major massive purge is no substitute
for a change in policy congress must
exercise its duty to provide a check
on the executive branch you pretty much
have to be a yes
person otherwise you do not last long
nielsen will be known
for implementing a cruel policy oh my
gosh it's so bad
that cabinet secretaries get berated
about policies
totally out of their area of
responsibility even
well i'm dismayed to hear that you're
willing to drive our health care system
off the cliff with no plan for replacing
it
i think the prem your premise that the
justice department makes health care
policy is simply wrong we
we take legal positions in cases
okay how barr remained as cool as a
cucumber is beyond me
now even as the hearing was ending
chairman jose serrano we warned you
about him last year
couldn't give the condescension and
self-righteousness arrest
i grew up politically in the 60s
that's where i developed a lot of my
feelings
about things in our great country it's
very troublesome
to see a justice department against the
law of the land we lean on you
to come through for this country and
when we see you
taking sides against the law of the land
or taking sides that
we may not think is in the best interest
of the american people
it troubles us nevertheless we want to
thank you
for your testimony today yeah
we all should be thanking bill barr and
the entire trump team
now despite a constant stream of
defamatory attacks
and scurrilous charges from the
democrats the trump administration has
still managed to accomplish
an enormous amount for our country with
the economy the courts
on trade etc mindful
persistence versus mindless resistance
americans will have a clear choice in
2020
and that's the angle